Hi, everyone.
I'm Guil, and in this course, we're gonna
learn about the wonders of CSS or
cascading style sheets.
It's one of the core technologies for
designing and
building websites and applications.
So, no matter what kind of website or
web app you wanna build, you'll have to
use CSS.
You might have already used CSS, or you've
seen it in action in previous courses.
In this course,
we're gonna dive a little deeper into many
of the core concepts of CSS.
To get familiar with the most important
part of css,
we'll build a simple landing page for the
beautiful city of Lake Tahoe, California.
First we'll learn the different ways we
can apply CSS to a page.
Then we'll add those nice design layers
with basic selectors,
common CSS properties and values.
We'll even use some of the latest features
in CSS.
By the end of this course, you'll be a few
steps closer to being a CSS pro.
Are you ready?
Then let's get started.